was the best shooter in the Warriors in
Sami no no you know no of course we know
Stefan better are you so I'm gonna kill
shoot come on let's go what's up
this is Serge Ibaka aka my food chef
welcome to our hungry are you today I
will be cooking for my boy Kevin Gerardo
have no clue sir anything can be
possible with this guy I will be cooking
him snake
[Music]
pay attention
first up I'm gonna boil the snake long
snake so now I'm gonna let the snake get
boiled for 10 or 15 minutes we're ready
to go and a lot of people call my boys
snake today he's about to eat snake
because snake no it's snake you got it
yeah I don't understand
let's do it it's time oops you're moving
I'm joking
time to put some seasoning now so now
it's time to put my corn starch here Oh
[Music]
jordu you making it worse now you can
see how we need to go clean myself hey
Jordy happy to get ready all right let
me take a picture okay let's go okay I'm
gonna show you babe youuuu serge ibaka
baby
I don't know what combo yeah I got you
good you know you know I do man thank
you for coming bro of course man had to
say too many of these installments I
ain't been on one yet I had to come yeah
one good thing about you you always
support your teammates a phone call or
the phone you know so I appreciate it
thank you for coming bro don't have baby
things going on in general not good you
know rehabbing I'm walking down doing
more every day
yeah every week I'm getting better
looking forward to you know the next few
months see how I progressed you could
read about this shirt nah man for now
I'm just chillin man I'm just taking the
data time I'm not expecting to play at
all but you know who knows you know [ __ ]
you brother
I'm Teddy bra take your time this time
and I'm definitely gonna take as much
time as I need I'm planning on sitting
out the whole season so ya know I want
to beat ya'll that's why I came out this
that's a boot camp I bet I want you to
win one that
I was like come on Katie kind of let me
get one here how's that bro you already
got to be I mean - I just needed that
three in a row you know we needed that
you know I'm saying y'all came out of
nowhere I didn't even think y'all was
gonna make the finals but yeah i was
playing well again so I had to see what
I can do how you feeling now that you're
a champ I feel blessed bro like when you
win this like wow it's beautiful it's
like and you see then you can see really
all the hard work you put in it off you
realize some bigger than yourself like
the whole city is a part of it yeah
whole organization everybody get a
couple extra dollars you know it just is
good Bob's all around so I was happy you
want but just you nobody else you know
the action in a playoff when you went
down remember
yeah what do you feed them I don't that
moment I hope that's what life flashed
before my eyes I thought about
everything I did from like the first
time I played it to that you know I'm
saying that was the first time that
something like that ever happening me on
the court and I just I guess it just
relaxed me a bit as I thought about it
because like I've been through
everything this is nother something else
that I got to get over so yeah let me
get my walk to the locker room I figure
I was next but you know what happened
right so when you are down and then I
start the ball and not play but in my
head it was like you throw it down and
you just you just go so sure it's Nick
again yeah I didn't want to turn it I
was like you said that was that okay is
like it's kind of serious - first of all
you need switched out and I was like wow
just research on me even though I'm a
little hobby right now there's a bucket
that is crazy how fast my switch cuz in
the matter next second it was like I was
on the ground thinking about my whole
basketball career so it's just like it
happened so fast and once I got back to
the back end realize what happened I was
just like all right man let me figure
out where can I get surgery you know I'm
salves trying to move on to the next
step so fast and try not to dwell on it
too much now maybe I know you feel some
type of way about it but I want
apologize to you for our fans what
happening you know no commas you know in
your luck
the part of the game is apart you know I
know I soaked up copy of you where you
know I was on okay yeah all that I
understand I understand no it wasn't hey
the moment yeah you know we have we
agree have one of the best fans you know
classy fasten you know it wasn't either
moment where was exciting to see the
whole thing this year Toronto's first
time and the finals they treated it like
it was like it was no but it was fun to
like take a little jab at the fans you
know I'm always going to take a jab at
the Raptors fans cuz we lost to them in
the final so we'll talk [ __ ] as much as
I can but yeah do you think if you
didn't go down you guys would be sure
are you sure about it man are you honey
please send my brother yes it was hot
baby if you put it in front of anything
I can believe anything so yeah yeah but
I'm tell you another no you say yeah I'm
so you know why but good wheels like a
fire nobody could stop us I was like we
may get we may go to Game seven
but the wing was we was balling to her
confidence let's put it like this if you
are going to a game seven or the two
champ champ y'all not winning that game
y'all know I mean y'all had to win at
six
which I did but if I was out there if
you didn't beat us at home we almost did
you guys at five you know that what yeah
you're almost all right I'm talking
about Game six
okay I almost lost anyway play one out
you're almost lost so Game six we just
we were smack child at the crib and then
Game seven
I know for show y'all wouldn't know you
could have a pair drop in y'all locker
room in Game seven walking into that
arena like y'all have been so shook yeah
so you know I love your team no man yes
y'all play hard as hell the whole
playoffs and I'm like I just I just
really Rock whoo ha yeah I play a are
coach like he not gonna create the best
X's and O's but he know exactly which I
need to do to win a possession yeah did
you like playing with Dwyers
yeah it was fun of course you want you
want to Shepherd you then we are success
our office was unstoppable
we had great defense and we play in
front of the best fans in
at that point better than Toronto fans
no way you know that come oh man
first of all let's put up some respect
on the champ now we have a natural champ
hey like when you want a buddy was
respecting you wider so now we have the
actor a champ so put some respect and
her name you are you alright you
harvesting right on that but the fans
though yeah it's different
I respect the fans that the worried
friends better why did you leave them I
mean is another opportunity for me to
play for another team I wasn't it wasn't
that big of a deal you know I'm saying I
was just I want to play for the nets
there's on the East Coast close to home
the nest is solid in his New York City I
could pick my game up and play anywhere
did it why did you choose Brooklyn white
no the Knicks could be the Knicks too
easy you know you're exceeding the white
cheese booking I just like the
organization as far as just the
direction they were going in a bunch of
young guys that played in the playoffs
before you know I think the Knicks
players there are good young players but
they still need a little bit more
experience to match where I was in my
career so it was nothing major against
the Knicks I just think Brooklyn was
farther along in the process of being
like a contender are you excited to play
with curry
yeah for sure for sure you know playing
with staff and Russel and seeing a top
level of point guard and how they work
and then being around Kyrie
you know it's the same thing the
standard data point guard says everyday
is what kind of leaves the team you know
so I'm excited to play alongside him and
see see where we go what was the hardest
did she send to make living or Kissy to
warriors or living warriors to come here
and I'll live in OKC for sure I'm gonna
spend eight years there yes you have my
family there you don't send my whole
family lived out there I mean bought
houses and did everything and you know
I'm saying like grew up as if in my
twenty so it was hard to leave that
place and leave like all the equipment
got everybody there the support staff
and obviously my teammates what I
understood I felt I figured y'all would
understand cuz that's just business but
like the other people I felt away about
and it took me a while to make the
decision was the best shorter in the
Warriors for the best yeah sure Steph
Steph yeah okay you told me to know no
you know no I'm
saying of course we know steady bear
sugar you know I know come on now I'm
gonna flat out so we know you can you
get another pullover they're coming you
know that blue and it's gonna add a nice
cash but stuff the best shooter step the
best rate okay as a please play when he
gets hot I'd never see nobody get mad at
scorcher have before but stuff is the
best the basic we shoot from an issue so
pretty and it's so effortless okay we
get stick I'm probably like one a is
staffed by like one a to like you know
I'm saying like I'm a little bit of bus
stuff you like just a tiny bit
underneath no I know you can shoots just
that little bit what do you remember
about me I say wookie you don't kiss
yeah me I say we can't even kiss me what
do you know about it just learn English
after every practice what do we got
going on here it's like a daycare we
gotta teach to do how to speak English
but man crazy but when you got there
though like I didn't see you play before
until you played that first day of
picked up and everybody kept saying like
so much you block shots like no other
and he can shoot us like in case you
shoot then you start showing us I mean
then it was everything was bottoms
especially from like I mean you had to
pick and pop I'm here that was money
we've the kid and sure you see you are
now as a champ
yeah thank you now we go through the
check yeah I got to though you go yeah
but the chips each intro I'm gonna catch
you I'm gonna catch you we will see
maybe we get one together oh yeah you
never know
it is impossible bro I'm saying you know
the one thing about you know bro you
know like you made me feel so
comfortable yeah when was you know okay
when I moved next door to you I think
that's when we got time yeah next door
to me I used to walk down here every
walk up tomorrow
we just got tight over that time and
then we I both had gotten better as
players and had some success like it was
just perfect timing for us why did
happen if we we had to stay together no
comma
yeah I mean who know I mean at that
point when we lost James I think we're
still trying to figure out how to fill
that void you know for longest I feel
like if James did leave us with no video
James
you know I agree yeah I for sure I mean
he probably had the same type of impact
his managing oh yeah I'm not saying we
don't want as many championships but
like the way he came off the bench and
and affected the game yeah it was to
that impact but I'd rather see him
flourish that's just like a whole player
like instead of just limited limited
James to a six man so it worked out well
for everybody for a group of us like
sometimes I see what during like man I
wish we could at least one yeah one I
don't believe you like we are so good so
talented but we accomplished some crazy
things to be that young imagine we for
21 22 year olds making the finals today
it'll be crazy so we lose that team
before anybody we accomplished so much
and then result in the championship but
all that talent under one roof you know
I'm saying we had so many dudes that
could do a lot out there and it's hard
to put 22 23 year old in a box and be
like you need to do is just this serves
you only need the blocks shots and
rebound like nah you can shoot post up
gonna do it all so it's like you want to
still expand your game and winning a
championship
you got to minimize your soul just a
little bit that's something that's one
of the reason because we was sure your
yeah and how ego we didn't know when to
turn how you go on and off but it's
easier now for you to know that hey of
course I wanted to bad like back then if
you have to play five six seven straight
game where you score 10 or only 15 point
you'll be comfortable with that to me
yeah he'll know exactly let some say it
was young
but now you can now you can do it I mean
I'm not accepting that now but like me
not gonna pay off you can't do it now no
if you have to score 15 point for your
team to win we're not winning the first
[Laughter]
the win again but I get what you're
saying
you see I have to shoot like let's say
it's 10 is 12 shots
13 shots in the playoffs so let's say
like you know okay let's see like five
shots you know the serve that I'm gonna
only get five shots to be win again you
about that
you're saying is that if you slice it in
half yeah shot attempts you gotta be
alright with it yeah each other [ __ ] yo
ego gonna take a hit exactly how ego sad
and that's it's tough sometimes but hey
what do you think about Russell and
James teammate I wanna see what it's
like I think Russ getting out of OKC
you're saying something different
different yeah I'm saying side of
Oklahoma City there's gonna be cool to
see and then back then to back together
you know you know that was jokesters
from day one yeah that was always I'm
from LA to it so that was with each
other all the time you know back in our
younger days playing so I think was
gonna be shooting you we read read them
to Jon let them have that over there
how's your wrist chief of gents
it's been good I sail actually last week
and you know we was when I first went to
the Warriors obviously angrily talked to
many NBA players you know I'm saying and
James is one of the guys that you know
obviously grew up with in the league so
not talking to him for a couple years
just you know moving to the new team and
not really staying in contact it was
tough because I love him so much but now
I think we're in a good place so we're
gonna go through our ups and downs and
relationships and Russell Russell same
thing same thing same thing you know how
that goes you know so many people got in
between you know it was just bad
communication you know like say
something in the media and then a media
person X Russell as if I framed it
towards him and then sang with me so it
was just like miscommunication through
airwaves and he's trying to play the
game that might have got in between what
food did you eat growing up we had to
survive bro so hot dogs things like we
had a good day it was like beef
stroganoff and like like box food like
frozen food a lot of frozen food but we
went to Benihana on one time coming up
and I was like the best cuisine I had
and so I got to delete oh yeah yeah do
you remember when I moved to a kcid
I used to hate a barbecue sauce
yes I'm taking a risk like right yes see
straight rights Weiss yeah rice beef the
straight of my amps can you cook
no how come even eggs on my leg I can
make I can whip up some breakfast but
that's about it
my baby want some breakfast in the
morning I could well perhaps so you know
I'm saying house bacon eggs you know you
see what do you mean by baby baby you
say whoever's you know when I wake up
the next morning our universe if we have
a baby
we he said no he said my baby so are you
in a relationship
no no when was the last time keeping
John was anniversary [ __ ] two years ago
two years ago for how long I was like
eight months nine months that's that's
the longest you ever been and I said
[ __ ] yeah personal life because I'm your
brother
you I know but you press a lot already
well now I want other people to know
that people who love you who support you
they need to know about it right they
always see us they'd have a
basketball-sized didn't about that
yeah that's all I need to know okay all
these no all right
who's your favorite eco sure like I'm a
little old to have a celebrity crush
right now I mean no you cannot hold it I
say because you mean that's like for me
I'm sure I know you very much sure you
have Cedric gosh wouldn't even see her
picture on social media you that day
okay you have crushed I think a lot of
women are beautiful bro Marie of course
I know you don't have a crush your
celebrity crush you know here you know
how this work here I asked question you
answer this is my house if you wanna we
needed a bath you are you are you are
you saying English when your husband or
you say no you didn't conducted the
whole interview are you saying right now
cuz you I mean I'll look at your pitches
all the time at you post and I see a lot
harder than the Nico
a lot of these women always come to my
surgery pockets ergy bargain okay and
you turned it to this like full-on
section so are you single I'm single
it's easy you don't answer me it's okay
because we're gonna have some specific
questions here if you don't answer those
questions you have to take shots okay
one second you want to skip one question
about the saber de crush I'll let you go
with that one
come on let this one you wanna you know
we're not scared moving on we should
smell a drink
exactly every time you don't own Sur you
take a shot first question who is the
better player stefank
or worse or worse book stop okay
why you thinks differently is the better
is better player than what source book
because it is you but okay makes sense
second questions when was the last
female saver the UDN female yeah you
diem you can check your phone if you
want if you do if you forget about it
seventh Street she's singer semi street
yeah that's the last one a DML yeah okay
let me see let me see her no you know
you sitting there by your rules okay
good okay last one
once they really turn you down you're
trying to hook up with and then they
turn you down like you know you was
coming to try to hook up with her like
I'm kidding around and I'm saying
two-time NBA champ means my me okay I
mean I'm saying okay now you go ahead no
come on baby you know I mean a lot of
girls have turned me down under said it
really but at least once like you try to
you know go dinner with them or I don't
know that's name number or whatever they
turn it down or respond to you oh yeah
now you say yeah come on that's happened
anybody whoa
before you got whatever keri hilson turn
me down okay
what so hey guys me you guys miss me but
you guys called miss yada
no but that's that's that's no count bro
that does count that does count
no no no what that's she's a celebrity
and she turned me down
since you wanna ask you tell questions I
gave us a tough answer that's the only
one I could say that I was pressing like
really trying to get it and she's like
ah no I was like cool you know what I
don't know about it I didn't want to
drink that so I had to be real alright
next stop book how hungry are you I'm
pretty hungry man when you talk for a
long time I know unis sneak you know and
then I might be sometimes no you know
snake okay anyway I know snake though it
snake
and so today I decided to cook a snake
for you obviously today no today
cannabis snake and when you asked me to
my show you know why it's coming I mean
I can't eat no snake but I wanted to
show and every time but late you should
you should at this on most I never even
heard it's my inner snake-like even
frying a snake yeah how many do a few
you don't write B or do you want a tea
snake come on eat with you okay but
that's a bit okay usually bro the show
show you scared not but maybe I'm maybe
that helped me with my fear of snakes
oh maybe I eat one oh you scared of
snakes you can fear snakes
yeah yeah yeah look like now I look like
chicken almost like this yeah yeah look
fish boy okay this how we're gonna eat
and I'm gonna eat that like we'd never
forget together right and family cheetah
power here
Vega book as good for very good try
you're gonna be surprised
would you get this recipe no I buy it a
snake and I put the recipes you just
made this all yeah I'm a dancer
very good
I said you carefully good bones
I like that place get up out yeah
yeah perfect you know what kind of snake
is this huh black mama black mamba so
you give me back my money it's right
yeah I fried it it's a fight I'm gonna
dry solid yeah big snake like you don't
really have a lot a lot of small snake I
appreciate you giving me this
opportunity I wouldn't never a mistake
of my life okay
and he snakes ass [ __ ] is snake but
it's next so that's meanest is no snake
that's what come here brother
yes sir appreciate that
nah man Thank You fun s my bro here
Kevin Durrant the two NBA champ and a
new NBA champ that's how we do it
[Music]
[Applause]
good I'm getting part of myself a fight
pool just a tiny bit I guess yeah this
is dope yeah it's good no this gonna be
your best one yet okay
[Music]